[Applause]
gardner working laterally comes out keem
lets it go this one hit escape side of
that geeky and renae back to grab it
that net was open and then it was shut
quickly more vintage arena again shot
from the point gets blocked goes to the
traffic outside he's got to acquire
where that puck is
and just big push across closes all the
holes and look at this glove
best club in the league
[Applause]
that is just diving larceny you can see
biaxa read this thing and
go to the gallop to join
a little patience
beautiful shot pass to set up the
backdoor play everything set up
perfectly for him
elevated it and rene just killed his
knight
bang around it popped
[Applause]
from hell renee scrambled back actually
feet underneath the goal line still able
to get out catches enough of that puck
just to steer it wide
to the top side watch the
how close that comes
harrowingly close
to the post on the far side
lacey nelson has an open man sherry
michael shot green tumbling somehow kept
it out how did he do that
pekka stacks the patch
oh my goodness what a save
sharks will
dump it back into san jose ice pictures
did you see that back-to-back brilliant
stops by pekka rita
unbelievable
best saves of the series so far
[Applause]
wow even the fans here appreciate that
those were two outstanding saves
elected pass to the point montour
towards the net tipped up in the air
what a save by renee renae is down what
an unbelievable save now this is
a deflected pocket it is looks like it's
almost behind renee and the reaction
pecorine with that blocker
pretty incredible man
gets a little piece of this
this puck's going in
[Music]
throws his stick
gets a little piece of that puck and
that is a game saver
toughest save
of the game so far watch the knob of his
stick wow i mean the the stick pulls out
of his hands and hits the knob i mean
you talk about catching a break early on
that is something i don't think i've
ever seen a save like that before
and then his corral there and set
[Applause]
scrambling
one save two saves
getzel comes in he's got a wide open net
and renee with the glove the trapper an
incredible stop
hits with speed hits to the net and ring
stopped it is it hit it's loose
and bonito came up with it but how did
that stay out oh fabulous save
we'll take a look at how close
roufey hints was to giving dallas the
lead as it slides under
pekka ring about the puck and the lefts
skate by pekka rine to keep that out
crawford will go to the bench again riya
will try rene going deep for the empty
net it is
[Music]
unbelievable
oh he's been trying that a couple of
times over the last few years oh my god
and what a perfect opportunity and he
buries the blackhawks
well he's officially done it all now
that is just unbelievable from behind
the net look at him gets it off takes a
look
up and over just launches that thing
their defenders at the far blue line
gets it over
in the back of the net over kirby dock
look at this
this is just a thing of beauty
floats it all the way over the neutral
zone lands on the other side of the blue
line